Next let's try inserting an element.
We could take the approach we used with
BST's, start at the root then move
down the tree one level at a time and do
comparisons until we find an open spot.
However, if our element is bigger
than most of the parent nodes or
even the root we'll need to
shuffle the tree around a lot.
As such, we take a different
approach to inserting here.
We can stick the new element in
the next open spot in the tree.
Then we heapify.
Heapify is the operation in
which we reorder the tree
based on the heap property.
Since we care that our parent
element is bigger than its child,
we just need to keep comparing our
new element with its parent and
swapping them when the child is bigger.
We can take a similar approach
to an extract operation
where the root is removed from the tree.
We stick the rightmost
leaf in the root spot
then just compare it to its children and
swap where necessary.
The runtime of insert and delete,
a more general case of extract ends
up being O of log in the worst case.
Ultimately the worst case would involve
moving an element all the way up or down
the tree and would roughly be as many
operations as the height of the tree.